[Music]
the more mamoa
the better get dirty inside the pages of
men's health yes
actually dirty like in mud the 41 year
old actor opens up about family life and
how he's not this giant superhero you
may think he is
saying quote i may look big and tough
but i'm not i'm nothing like khal drogo
i'm not even the king of my own house
i'm absolutely terrified of my wife
while lisa bonet may be the boss at home
jason seems to be flying solo in toronto
where he's filming his apple tv plus
series c
and hitting up some local record shops
but there's no question his family comes
first especially
after this tough year we've all gotten
so much closer my wife is very
sophisticated and smart and our kids and
i
are kind of like animals that need to be
trained a little better i'm constantly a
work in progress
and i've just been trying to get better
as a father and a husband
shawn mendes justin bieber monster yeah
their new single together comes out
friday and fans could not be more
excited
today sean joined apple music's zane
lowe and talked about how much the biebs
meant to him growing up it was a full
circle moment for me this guy who was
the reason i started singing yeah i was
nine when one time came out and i'd
and i completely was all in he was
obvious he was elvis to me and it was
like
to come back around and to have this
very human to human conversation with
him
and his truth to come into that song and
my truth to be there it feels like one
of the most special songs i've ever
wrote
and it's the end of an era conan o'brien
is saying farewell to his tbs late night
show
next june 2021 will mark conan's 11th
year hosting that show
and 28 years in the business there have
been many ups and downs of course most
famously the battle over nbc's the
tonight show
in 2009 conan landed the coveted hosting
gig after jay leno retired
only to lose it seven months later to
jay leno
but that's the past and the future is
still bright
yeah conan won't be signing off for good
he has signed up with hbo max for a
weekly variety series saying in a
statement quote
in 1993 johnny carson gave me the best
advice of my career
as soon as possible get to a streaming
platform
i'm thrilled that i get to continue
doing whatever the hell it is i do on
hbo max
and i look forward to a free
subscription